[Music]
edwin black describes how the automotive
and petroleum industries have encouraged
oil dependence in his new book internal
combustion he spoke about it recently in
a meeting of the american jewish
committee's institute for analysis of
global security in washington this is
just over an hour
our sponsor here the iags the institute
for the for the analysis of global
security and gal loft and a number of
people that he are working that he is
working with uh
names that you might know
uh are really making an important
contribution
to the question
of our addiction to oil and how we're
going to get off of that and i strongly
applaud the iags for all the work that
they're doing behind the scenes and in
in in every venue
to help us get off of oil
now
uh you may have seen from the trailer
that um i did lead a team of some 50
researchers in
100 repositories
uh everything from the uh
archives of british petroleum and iraqi
oil to the closed papers of thomas
edison
and
the papers of henry ford and we obtained
some 50 000 documents
and it led us to the conclusion
that since the beginning of recorded
time
there has never been a generation where
fuel and energy and transportation has
not been the domain of monarchs
and manipulous
and
monopolists
and that's what i did in this work in
order to understand
how we got addicted to oil i didn't just
go back to world war ii i didn't just go
back to world war one i actually went
back to the beginning of recorded time
i went back to ancient mesopotamia and
to the pharaohs to see just what was the
first fuel i don't know if anyone here
knows what the first fuel in the world
was does anyone have an idea
what was the first anyone
ox no any anyone else
manure
who said water
ron anyone else
firewood who sent firewood
right
it was wood
it was tim it was it was timber
timber
wood was the basis of civilization
because from wood came smelting
and that meant metal that meant tools
that meant weapons that meant
jewelry that meant religious objects
coins as a medium of exchange in fact
wood was more
valuable than gold because without wood
there was no gold
you could make gold
and so when the pharaohs and other uh
ancient uh
despots would um
would want to take over property and
territory they wouldn't just um take
over the empty quarter of the arabian
peninsula so they could have space they
they took over a wealthy resource rich
land and that was a land with wood
okay
um
let's say a little take an example like
cyprus does anyone know what the word
cyprus means
copper correct
that's right and the reason it's called
cypress was called copper was because
all although it's basically denuded from
wood now
it once was rich in forest lands and it
was used to
to provide timber for a smelting of
copper in fact i have some of those
ancient purchase orders
letters to the king from letters of
amarna and others talking about the
delay in providing timber
so um it's important to understand
that when a slave
died
he was just replaced with another slave
but when a tree was cut down that was 20
to 30 years waiting for that tree to
return and that meant that uh there was
always more and more land to conquer
all right let's bring this forward to
the uh
uh to the um medieval times of england
okay
and uh everybody here has heard of robin
hood right
but does anyone in this room with all
the educated people we have here know
why robin hood was hiding in the forest
anyone know
what
what about
wood
that was a guess right
that was a good guess
that's right wood
it was illegal to use wood
in medieval england
the king
owned all the woods
and very few people in the united states
know that there was in addition to the
common law there was something called
the forest law
and the penalty for peasants to use wood
to cook or to build furniture or tools
or was uh was execution and even after
the magna carta
when they became more humane the penalty
became
blinding and castration
so
wood was very important in medieval
times
and eventually as the navies were built
as more carriages were built as more
wood was used as more construction
occurred
uh there became a timber shortage and
that was the world's first
fuel shortage it was the timber shortage
in england when it became even more
impossible to use wood and so they went
to a substitute fuel does anyone know
what that was
who said call who else said call
you're both right
it was cold
some people in a certain area also had
peats
but
pete was just in rob
to become coal just need a few extra
million years
but coal was of course very very stinky
very very polluting
and
very very enviro environmentally
destructive
and what's important to understand is
that there are roads from coal
a complete anti do you have a note from
foreign foreign
c-span needs you to sit in front of the
microphone please
we're okay now
thank you
i never sit when i'm speaking but i'll
do it this time
i'm too nervous to sit okay
so
uh
from the pollution of coal
came the first anti-pollution movement
there were laws there were protest
marches there was a demography about
cancer deaths how
how many cancers in this part of the uh
village as opposed to that part of the
village in this part of the countryside
as opposed to that based upon the
smokestacks
and
this is important for us to know because
if someone were to tell you that this
whole
anti-pollution environmental green
movement started after the vietnam war
the truth is it started in the 1600s and
it's never died yet so we need to
understand that
okay there are rows
in this cold trade
the world's first energy cartel a secret
society that no one in the united states
has ever heard of and there are no books
in the united states which mention it
and this society is called
the hostmen
of newcastle
and the host men controlled
all the coal in england now how did they
control it it isn't that they mined it
isn't that they dug it out what they did
was they transported it down riverboats
and when uh and they were involved in a
lot of bribery a lot of skull doggery
there were protest movements about the
price
and when
the pressure uh was high
the hostmen would increase the supply of
coal and the price would go down then
right after the pressure would subside
like an election or something of that
nature the price would go back up and
the supply would be
manipulated
now uh the guys involved in
the transport of coal made it clear to
the world that you could own all the
coal in england
but if you couldn't move it downstream
you would freeze in winter and that's
important for us now because we
understand that you can have access to
all the oil reserves in the world and if
you can't get them past the straits of
hormuz you ain't got no oil and that's
important
now the
the hostmen
uh their industry developed an invention
for pumping water
out of the uh
out of the coal mines anybody know the
name of that invention
no one knows
the steam engine correct
and and then they put the steam engine
on wheels and what did that make
a locomotive right
what was that
that's a few centuries later
okay uh anyway they were now able to
transport
uh the call over
land instead of just water and it opened
up great expanses of the country it
opened up england it opened up the
continents of latin america of
of africa of europe it opened up the the
united states it also brought man face
to face with a new phenomenon one that
actually had a neurological effect
speed
that's right you did guess correctly
have you heard one of my speeches before
okay
in human history that's right railroads
that's why railroads were important why
because until that time can everybody
see me okay until that time you could
only go 5 to 15 miles an hour
on a horse
but speed
allowed man to go 80 90 100 miles an
hour i want you to think about this
there's an optical impact
because when you're going a hundred
miles an hour
and we've all seen the experience
and you look out the sides everything is
a blur your surroundings are a blur you
can only focus on what's right in front
of you
and since man discovered great velocity
there has been a change from which there
has been no read no retreat
now these great expanses
re
required communication and a device was
invented
to communicate across these hundreds of
miles anybody know the name of that
device
telegraph right
and what powered the telegraph
electricity good and where did they get
the electricity
cold wrong where did they get the
electricity where
water water no
fire no anybody know
okay batteries
they got it from little boxes
batteries
and the idea at that time was i know you
all got your blackberries but the fact
of the matter is in the 1800s they
called batteries wireless
wireless electricity
now of course when was electricity
discovered anybody know
galvani
actually before but that's a good guess
what does the word electricity mean
amber
so the ancient greeks
the ancient greeks discovered
electricity that's static electricity
there are three types of electricity
there's actually there's four
there's static electricity the second
type is natural electricity like with
ben franklin
and the third type is generate
electricity like we do in a utility and
the fourth type is when your book makes
the new york times bestseller list
or the washington post
okay
so uh how did we really get involved
with these batteries well the gentleman
here was clever enough to mention
galvani
and as you know galvani was dissecting a
frog and he cut into the frog with his
knife with his scalp with his scalpel
and he saw a spark and he said goodness
there's electricity in frog's legs
but that was not the case
the actuality was that that the metal of
his knife hit the metal of the plate
underneath the frog's legs and from
there came the spark and eventually they
were
able to capture this and contain the
electricity in a battery and
this brought
the science of battery this started the
science of batteries in its most real
sense
and it's two metals coming together with
a positive and a negative charge and i
can tell you this uh that thomas edison
was asked at the end of his career
we know how electricity works
but does anyone know why it works and
thomas edison said at the end of his
career
electricity has always been a mystery to
me and that's important to understand
because there's no one on earth who
knows why
these sub subatomic particles interact
the way they do they just do and from
their interaction comes the electricity
that powers our civilization
so we've got batteries and they're able
to put these batteries to together and
this was high tech at the time
all right so it's high tech that means
big corporations that means stocks
windows that means bank fraud that means
criminal collusion and all the batteries
at the end of the 1800s were renowned
for being criminal enterprises and it
was common to call
as many people called batteries
thievery as people today call software
vaporware if you know what that means
the software just often doesn't work
eventually the batteries did
work enough to be placed on horseless
carriages
and uh early on the land
the the land speed record for a mile a
minute was set
with an electric car now who knows when
that occurred
mile a minute
land speed record anybody know
19 what
19 five or seven no anybody else got a
guess
18 what
oh you're just guessing
that's a good guess
yeah it's 1899 outside of paris
all right that was the so-called red
devil
and uh he said the land speed record of
a mile a minute now it's important to
understand
that at that time in the 1890s
almost all the cars were electric cars
i know you've seen this movie about
electric cars in the last couple of
decades but but in truth in the early
part of the 20th century all the cars
were electric so how did we get to
internal combustion okay
after the american civil war
there was
an extraordinary number of trusts
monopolies
corporate collusion there was a copper
monopoly there was a rubber monopoly
there was an oil monopoly and believe it
or not
there was a bicycle monopoly
and there was one guy in hartford
connecticut colonel pope who controlled
all the bicycles in the united states
who could buy them who could sell them
who could make them and they did this
through
patent litigation i don't know if any of
you have ever known a patent attorney or
dated one or been married to one
but patent litigation has been a big
problem in this industry and so if
anyone tried to make a bicycle without
his license or permission he would sue
them well the bad the bicycle monopoly
of colonel pope
in hartford connecticut the columbia
bicycle company got together
with the battery monopoly there was a
battery monopoly and the successor to
this battery monopoly is now today xi
technologies the same company that makes
the little batteries that goes into your
flashlight
the battery monopoly
got together with the bicycle monopoly
to create the electric vehicle monopoly
specifically the electric vehicle
company in the electric vehicle company
in 1899 was determined to set up
electric vehicle services all across the
united states they attacked electric
taxi fleets in new york in chicago in uh
in boston all up and down the east coast
and they had a whole plethora
of electrical um
inventions and developments at
at that time
well
in the early part of this century there
were a bunch of guys
who thought that the electric car
was a girly car
why
because it was clean
it was just a push button it didn't
smoke
it didn't stink and stink is important
stink is important because all the
transportation at that time was stinky
now think about this for a second how
did anybody used to get around at in
1900
horses
manure correct and there was a lot of
horse manure in this country
there were 20 million horses
in the united states
they were doing all the mill work all
the transportation all the deliveries
the manure was everywhere the horses
were dropping dead on the street every
day they had to be carted back every
time it rained the cobblestones would
run the manure like in rivers have fun
walking across the street in that
and it was a source of malaria
tied that to the fact that the railroads
were spewing off cinders and smoke and
soot
throughout the domains of the of of the
railroad routes and so the clean
electric car was absolutely welcomed but
the internal combustion machine
developed by
names that you would
know now cadillac leland olds etc this
was a rumble car this was a smoky car it
was a faster car it had greater range
because nothing beats gasoline for
compactness and the amount of energy you
can pull out of it
and they also thought it was important
because it took a nice hand crank it
took a man to make and they used to say
that the electric car was a was a ladies
car and the internal combustion machine
was a man's car
so the um electric vehicle monopoly
bought a
worthless patent called the selden
patent
and they told the guys making the
internal combustion machines we're not
going to let you make cars
unless
you get a license from us and pay us
tribute these were all american guys
they were building these uh internal
combustion machines in their backyards
and in their garages and in their
stables one at a time they were very
expensive they were custom crafted
leather they were built for aristocrats
from for presidents of uh banks and
universities and they said we're gonna
fight you
and so litigation ensued and after a
number of years
the internal combustion machine
industry
got together with the electric vehicle
monopoly
to make a super cartel to control all
the bicycles the batteries the electric
vehicles and the internal combustion
machines
and they jointly decided to abandon
the clean electric vehicles
the technology that they possessed in
favor of the internal combustion machine
and they were going to keep this as a
very expensive mode of transportation
and they ran up against one guy who
refused to play ball now who was that
henry ford correct
henry ford in 1903 decided that he was
going to make an uh a model t
he was going to make a car a cheap car
for 500
a car for every man not just aristocrats
it was a cheap stripped down car to be
sure but it was basic transportation it
would have revolutionized uh this
country
and
he's actually the hero of my book to a
certain extent i know it's very hard for
a guy like me who has written about
henry ford is a great anti-semite and a
and uh and a colleague of hitler uh i
write about him as uh as a hero but
henry ford was um
uh
this was a period before henry ford
became an anti-semite this is before
world war one and so i i had to treat
the history honestly and i should also
say here
at the ford motor company knowing how
much investigation i've done
about their history cooperated
completely with me without ever knowing
what my work was and in fact all the
auto makers cooperate except for one
cooperated completely with my work so
henry ford
said
i'm not going to give in i'm not going
to join you and i'm going to make my
cars and there's nothing you can do
about you can litigate to your heart's
consent and they and these and the uh
the uh
the electric vehicle and internal
combustion machine monopoly said we're
going to sue you we're going to sue your
customers we're going to sue your
dealers and we're going to sue your
suppliers anyone who gets close to your
car
and so when you bought a uh a model t
from henry ford i'll show you an
interesting ad can i borrow
this you got not only a warranty
you got a defense attorney
henry ford said anyone who bought his
car here's one of his typical full-page
ads in a detroit page
in a detroit paper offered you a defense
console just to drive the car so i want
you to understand that these forces are
not so much energy driven
as populist
socioeconomic political this was a
populist movement and so they fought a
horrible litigation
for about seven years i've got the
deposition of henry ford uh the files
about this long
and in 1911 ford prevailed
the selden patent which was used to
litigate frivolously was struck was
struck down
and henry ford was allowed to sell his
car to everybody the model t
proliferated uh model ts were going all
over the united states and now there was
pollution in soot
in not
just not just along the railroad tracks
but now it was at every intersection and
every street
and henry ford realized that he had won
the battle but was losing the war
and so he and thomas edison
got together
to undertake a secret project which has
never been written about in the united
states i know there are many biographies
and books on edison ford you will not
find this in any of them
to return this country to electric
vehicles this is 1912
and they put millions of dollars into
this project to develop electric
batteries
that would be home generated they would
be generated by wind turbines in your
backyard or in or a kerosene generator
in your in
in your basement
and
this is going to revolutionize the
country well um something strange
occurred
the forces of internal combustion to
come the companies that opposed us were
all lobbying against a ford and edison
asking him not to do this it was going
to obsolete the internal combustion
machine
there was going to be there were no gas
stations at the time
and there was a complete infrastructure
for swapping out batteries you merely
roll the battery over a pit they would
take your your battery out swap it out
for a fresh one it would take 40 to 70
seconds and you could go on on your way
general electric had developed a device
called the electrons it looks like a
parking meter
but in fact it was supposed to be
everywhere along the road
for the purpose
of you would shop you would park you
plug your car in it gets recharged
we don't need to re reinvent the wheel
ladies and gentlemen we just need to
excavate it from where it was buried a
hundred years ago
so
a funny thing happened
all these advanced
batteries in orange new in orange new
jersey are in perfect working order when
they get shipped to detroit
they get to detroit they don't work
he ships more they get to detroit the
engineering tests show that they've been
tampered with they're false
and he's complaining someone is
tampering with these batteries someone
is falsifying the engineering reports
and eventually the project dragged on so
long trying to get these batteries to
work it was
it was subsumed
when edison said he would develop a
battery that would be tamper-proof
overnight his entire compound of
numerous buildings and labs burnt down
in a mysterious fire
also not written about in any of the
books
on edison
and it and the ironic thing is that all
of his rooms were fireproof
and he had a fire brigade on premises
they never explained to fire and they
were confused because all of the really
flammable materials like kerosene and
alcohol and turpentine never caught fire
and then came world war one
and that was the beginning of the end
of clean electric
in this country
now that's the end of the story of
electric in
automobiles but it's not the end of our
story of our addiction to oil because
many of you might remember that this
country had electric trolleys
uh many of you remember trolley has
anyone here ever ridden a trolley
okay where where was your trolley
and where was yours
boston very good in yours montreal
montreal very good okay so
there were trolleys were a beloved form
of transportation in this country they
were clean they were electric
uh there were 15 million passenger
boardings of trolleys
in the uh 20s okay
and uh these trolleys uh meet me in
saint louis they had songs bomb they
were hop-on they were hop-off every city
had a trolley every town had a trolley
these trolleys were owned
by corrupt businessmen who ran the
electric utilities
and these corrupt businessmen who ran
the electric utilities uh
ran afoul of the fdr administration and
the new deal and there came a law in
1935 a reform act
called puka
p-u-h-c-a very aptly named that's the
public utility holding company act
and this act required all the utilities
to divest themselves
of
their electric trolleys
so what the
utilities did was they began to
manipulate the value of these trolleys
began to stop the repairs deflate the
value and along come
five guys
five uneducated bus drivers
the fitzgerald boys from minnesota
and these bus drivers
suddenly have millions of dollars in
their pockets
they buy up the trolley lines
they pull they immediately pull up the
rails
they pave them over
they either uh
get rid of sell off or burn the trolleys
and public bonfires
and they replaced them
with diesel and gasoline burning motor
buses
and this went on city after city it
started in little galesburg illinois
moved to beaumont texas eventually it
got baltimore tampa
the cities of the west coast
and finally the fbi began looking into
the mysterious company the secretive
company called national city lines
and national city lines which owned all
of these trolleys in some 40 cities
national city lines
it turns out according to the fbi
investigation was secretly being funded
by general motors
in a criminal conspiracy
along with
phillips petroleum
standard oil
mac truck and firestone
and the criminal conspiracy which has
now been confirmed
by three branches of government
in the united states the
the judiciary the the legislative and
the executive the criminal conspiracy
involved
buying stock preferred stock on
condition of tearing up these trolley
lines and replacing them with gasoline
gas guzzling and petroleum using trout
motor buses and these buses were stinky
they were belching they were smokey they
were on they were unpopular and
eventually
general motors and his co-conspirators
and its executives were prosecuted
for a criminal conspiracy to subvert and
undermine through monopolistic practices
the trolleys in some 40 cities they were
found guilty
and the corporation was fined for this
work guess 40 cities down and they had
hundreds more targeted you may have seen
me on pbs late uh recently i had the hit
list of all the cities that they wanted
to get anybody can guess what general
motors was fined for undermining
transportation in 40 cities
forty thousand
do i hear another number
five thousand dollars
and their executives who were also found
guilty guess what they were fined
anybody want to guess
a hundred dollars who else has a guess
one dollar
they didn't pay
they they appealed to one dollar to the
supreme court
they lost
the case was up was up was upheld
and eventually
this technique a spread of its own
momentum to other cities and of course
criminals are not the best guys to
run mass transit
and so the mass transit companies went
broke and when the mass transit
companies went broke they were forced
upon the
forces upon the the municipalities and
that's how the municipalities
got mass transit
because the private mass transit
companies
of the early decades
when broke in this fashion
now what was je while general motors was
here
undermining
mass transit in the united states
fighting after fdr uh are
rebelling against the new deal what was
general motors doing overseas during the
30s and early 40s anybody want to guess
building trolleys no anybody want to
guess
selling trucks to hitler that's right
you read the book
you did read the book okay no fair
that's right
general motors was the biggest
automotive source in nazi germany
it wasn't daimler it wasn't ben's it was
opal
gm opel which they controlled a hundred
percent
and gm
made the blitz truck
which was used for the
blitzkrieg
and they were the leading supplier of
this technology and they also gave
tetraethyl to the uh nazis
to accelerate their mo their mobility
and when alfred sloan the first half of
sloane kettering uh
propositioned the hitler regime about
this he told he told them we are not
only going to make
cars for the third reich we're going to
help you recover your entire economy
we're talking about
15 to 20 000 people going back to work
we're talking about buying power we're
talking about suppliers we're talking
about dealers we're talking about the
invention of a gas station network and
we're talking about a brand new
invention called the autobahn
all of this emerging in the first years
of the hitler regime
and that is why it's true
thomas watson the head of
of international business business
machines got the first hitler award the
eagle
for a distinguished service by a
foreigner to the third reich but after
he got it general motors got it
i know general motors would like you to
think that they lost control
of their
subsidiary
during the war this is absolutely not
the case
general motors
had control right up in right when the
war started in 1939 6 a.m september uh
first 1939 they had control they
continued to make these products for uh
the the hitler regime right going
through uh uh the um 1940 and in 1941
the uh company was put into escrow
because of course we were at war with
germany and the
native-born german managers were placed
in control and after the war general
motors got all those profits
that were held in escrow for them during
those three to four years
and you should understand that this
company absolutely bonded with the
hitler regime what i'm talking about is
is patrician pictures of adolf hitler on
on the gm cover we're talking about
hitler's speeches being piped in to the
uh to the fact to the factory and we're
talking about
uh our consistent donations of trucks
to the storm troopers
with advertising
the proud sponsors of the storm troopers
so this was a com so uh gm
was a a a good conduct goose stepping
corporate citizen in nazi germany at the
same time they were doing what they were
doing that caused them to be prosecuted
for interfering with our transportation
here and it's important to understand
who are the companies
that are claiming to bring us to
salvation to cure our problem and this
is giving you an example
so you know the rest of the story that
um uh the the americans won the war
and uh gm was very important to that war
and in fact uh the guy in charge of the
uh nazi subsidiary mooney was uh one of
the key officials who was uh uh placed
in charge of the uh war effort for the
united states
so general motors had coming and going
on both sides of the atlantic
and so now we want to ask
we have an oil addiction
i'm bringing you up to the present tense
i knew i would bring you up from the
pharaohs to the present tense and here
i'm doing i'm i'm doing it
this addiction
is killing us
it's killing our environment
cigarette by cigarette mile by mile
it is like cigarette by cigarette we are
uh unfreezing the ice we are warming the
earth fossil fuels and once you unfreeze
this ice you cannot re-freeze it it is
killing our lungs
mile by mile there are micro fine
particles
even
myself and all the people who came who
drove here to hear me speak have done
their part to poison the lungs
incrementally of the people who were
who are suffering from this internal
combustion machine and the american lung
association and of course the people in
the air quality district in california
have a complete understanding of this as
do the major groups who are involved in
fighting uh the environmental impact
we're killing
our treasury our pocketbook we're
killing our pocketbook
our money is being transferred at a
fantastic rate to the middle east who
don't approve of our way of life to a
group of people people who in many cases
use our money to buy airplane tickets to
fly into the world trade center
and we are hurting our very way of life
now how do we get off
okay
first of all there are solutions
right now there are bridge technologies
we can do things this week and there are
things we can do later let's first talk
about the cng car from honda okay does
anyone here know that honda makes a cng
car
a compressed natural gas car an oven gas
car
do you know
anybody here know okay no one knows that
does anybody know
that a gal in georgia
stood her boyfriend up at the chapel and
took a greyhound bus to vegas
and left him waiting there you all know
about her what's her name
the runaway bride
why am i bringing this up
because on the day that honda announced
their cng car
mankind's first step away
from
gasoline stations with a home fueling
center right in your garage
you'd never see a gas station again the
runaway bride ran away
and they weren't covered
and that's it and it's as simple as that
it was the runaway bride so now
everybody knows what the headlights on
the runaway ride look like and no one
knows what the head the headlights on
the honda cng car look like
but the fact is there's 5 million cng
cars in the united states
excuse me in in the world
300 000 are made by one manufacturer
and that is honda and of course there's
a home refueling center that can be
purchased and and so if if you have a
fleet or you have a home usage you can
get off the gas stations all together
this is not a permanent solution because
as you well know a cng is a fossil fuel
it's bad for for for the environment but
those who want to get us off of gas
stations
those who want us to stop using oil at
least temporarily could right now
develop cng fleets and you also need to
understand that these five million
vehicles in the world who's making them
the big three
they're being made for countries outside
of the united states but not in the
united states
okay so there's the honda cng car
but what's more important than that
is the real step
and the real step is going to be plug-in
electric
it's going to be true
truly flexible fuel cars that can burn
everything from biodiesel which is just
anything from french oil to
waste oils to methanol to sugarcane
ethanol to cellulosic which is of course
very important and
and of course that brings up the
question of
corn ethanol now does anyone in this
room think that corn ethanol is a good
idea for this country anyone raise your
hand
nobody here
okay you do okay and you and you and you
do
unfortunately
corn corn corn ethanol takes about a
gallon to a gallon and a quarter
depending upon the study
of oil and petroleum products
to create a single gallon
of ethanol
gallon to a gallon a quarter and the
refineries are being built at such an
extraordinary rate
they must burn
hundreds of tons of coal
so when they say
yellow is green
they really mean it's green
for big corn
and for big oil now why do i say big oil
well that's because for every gallon
of corn ethanol that's used in this
country
the government pays a 51 cent support
subvention to the oil companies
that's your tax money so
it's a gallon of corn
corn ethanol
and 51 cents goes right to the oil
companies
now there's all not all ethanol is the
same and there's some very good ethanol
including cellulosic and sugar cane and
sugar cane ethanol you might have heard
about it comes from brazil at the
current time and it is eight times more
efficient to make
and use sugarcane ethanol it can be used
as an e100 which means it doesn't need
oil and it's generally made without
burning coal with a with a green
with a environmentally green
by-product called bagas
and this
which comes from our own hemisphere
is blocked from this country
by a 54 cent per gallon penalty tax
now they say they want us off of oil
why is there a 54 cent penalty tax
on every gallon of brazilian oil and in
excuse me uh
brazilian sugar cane ethanol
and restrictions on investment
and just think
of the rejuvenation of the caribbean
economies
if they could run sugarcane ethanol
supply houses there and they could be
exporters
and this 54 cent penalty tax
on
brazilian
sugarcane ethanol which must be lifted
immediately
is not the bush white house
this is congress
so when you see your congressman grab
them by the neck
and just say
why did you vote if you did vote for a
54 cent penalty tax per gallon
on brazilian sugar cane ethanol
and that brings me in addition to the
many other uh opportunities for
alt transportation to hydrogen and i
think that hydrogen is very much an end
game the final uh uh the final answer to
our uh
to our quest now remember a hydrogen car
is just an electric car now how far off
is a hydrogen car there's two types of
hydrogen cars there's the ice that means
an internal uh combustion
engine the first hydrogen car was a bus
developed in the 30s in australia the
first hydrogen
the first hydrogen
vehicle in the united states was a
tractor developed by alice chambers in
1953 and then a few years later general
motors had a van and
right now hydrogen is uh considered to
to be uh a great hope for uh solving our
energy crisis
well uh when i started doing this work
uh honda and toyota told told me about a
year and a half to two years ago that
the hydrogen car was about 10 years away
and then about a year ago they told me
it was three years of what three years
away
and just a couple weeks ago i find out
that bmw is going to start manufacturing
uh hybrid hydrogen cars
uh called the hydrogen 7. i'm told it's
a very luxurious vehicle it's going to
start producing that in december and
they're going to start deploying this
fleet in
in
in
spring
and then in the fall of next year of
2007 gm is going to bring out the sql
car and they're going to start ramping
up for mass production for hydrogen
for the chinese hydrogen economy
and honda may be the end game of all and
honda is developing the home energy
station they have it right now it's made
by plug power a company in upstate new
york and this will take compressed
natural gas oven gas right out of your
current infrastructure
crack the gas
and generate electricity to fuel your
entire home and five cars and this home
energy station is a little bigger than
than your uh air than your air
conditioning units
and this is about
three years away perhaps two two years
away
now it's important to understand
that we can do this
because although you've heard me talking
about a lot of corrupt and collusive
corporations the unindicted
co-conspirator
in this whole crisis
is the public
and public policy nobody took a gun to
anybody's head
and asked him to drive a hummer or a
navigator or an escalade
but i must ask your friends
do we really want to dig a hole in the
arabian desert
and pull some black gunk out of it
and drag it over the dead bodies of
americans
so we can power lawn mowers
why are lawn mowers
burning petroleum why are people dying
for lawn mowers
you want to go to uh you want to go down
the street to 7-eleven
and pick up a gallon of milk that's a
very expensive gallon of milk there's no
price that you can put at it and you
must remember as the people who are
sitting around this table know
the cost at the pump is merely the final
cost
the true cost of oil is the externalized
cost the full cost the cost of the
military the cost of the environment the
cost of the
state department the cost to our lives
the petrol political costs do not
discount the petrol political cost and
no one knows what's going to happen on a
moment's notice when the oil can be cut
off because of a hurricane in the gulf
or a hurricane in the middle east
and that is why
i have come upon the way we're really
going to get off of oil
and it's not because people like you and
me
can feel good about each other and buy a
hydrogen or methanol
or a plug-in electric car
the answer will be in fleets
and that's why
me alone
launched with no one's permission
the green fleet initiative
there will be no mass production
without mass purchasing
now how do we get mass purchasing
krispy kreme 4 500 vehicles
federal express 44 000 united parcel
service 88 000 united states government
600 000 vehicles the post office says i
want my delivery truck to look square
and ugly with the door open and the
drivers and the wheel on the wrong side
they will get it
and so what i'm asking everyone to do
is to understand that more important
than your vote
and more important than your letter to
the editor
is the fax machine
because
the companies that have the power
to supply these alternative cards i do
not mean the hybrid cars
which will merely extend our addiction
to oil by lengthening out the
lengthening out the supply i mean the
non-petroleum burning vehicles they need
the marketplace government regulation is
not the answer
the answer is that fleets fleet managers
organizations
county governments federal governments
universities everyone who controls the
fleet adopt a purchasing hierarchy where
you say we will purchase
the first reasonably cost properly
running hydrogen machine plug-in
electric methanol brazilian
sugar cane ethanol biodiesel
non-petroleum burning car and then
the car companies will bite each other
in the butt
to be the first one to sell you
thousands of cars not one or two at a
time but thousands of cars remember the
scale
please remember the scale there's 232
maybe 240 million vehicles on the street
that is not going to be replaced one at
a time that's going to have to be
replaced by a manhattan project
and how much was the manhattan project
25 billion dollars
in today's money
and how much was the hong kong airport
20 billion dollars
and how much did exxon mobil make in
profits in one quarter
and how much money a week are we
spending in iraq how many billions a
week in iraq
and so i want you to understand that we
have heard a lot of exaggeration
distortion
lies manipulation
from the media
from the government
from big business
but i'm telling you it can be done
if we can understand the history how we
became addicted
what's happening to us
be because we are addicted and how we
can kick that addiction a little bit now
and better later on do what we can today
and improve the situation tomorrow all
of my books
ibm and the holocaust war against the
week eugenics whatever i've written
about have explored a terrible past
so that we could salvage
a precious future
and i've written this book
to explore a terrible future so that we
can salvage our precious past thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen and i'll
take any questions that you have thank
you
[Applause]
okay so you had a question how does
hydrogen work how does hydrogen work
there are three ways first of all
hydrogen is the most abundant uh
substance in the universe as you well
know
uh
three of the most conventional ways are
this a uh the home energy station by
honda and by others is going to uh crack
compressed natural gas or other carrier
uh into uh um into both electricity and
will create fuel okay it's a chem
the fuel
it
it
it is going to be gas and it's going to
it's going to fuel a fuel cell
not an internal combustion machine that
fuel cell is going to generate
electricity
there is also electrolysis
where such as the city of las vegas now
is building a giant
electrolysis
array to take sunlight
to
create out of water
electricity from the hydrogen
and you have to understand we can
generate
the power needed the energy needed to
create the fuel no
fuel without energy and without power
from windmills from solar and the third
way is bacteria some of the best minds
in this country now are looking at ways
to increase the bacterial yields of
hydrogen to fuel our cars infrastructure
is the dirty word of energy what i'm
looking for is home generated
infrastructure infrastructure that will
create the hydrogen right in your
backyard which is what honda and other
people have in mind did you have a did
you have a question sir natural gas
is not renewable and it also has uh
contaminates the atmosphere that's right
natural gas anyone who's seen these
buses that says clean natural gas that's
another lie natural gas is not clean but
it's like natural hair spray it
it's an oxymoron
uh the fact of the matter is uh natural
gas is only about 66 percent as dirty
as regular oil pollution and so it's
cleaner
it's less dirty but it's not clean and
what we have to understand is this is an
infrastructure that's in place now most
parts of the country have oven gas they
have barbecue grill gas you can plug
into that so that is one solution there
are many solutions uh certainly um the
southern tier of the united states could
uh run off brazilian sugarcane ethanol
as long as you understand that there
ain't enough sugarcane ethanol in this
planet on this planet to run the u.s
fleet there are many ways and we should
think that there are different ways not
one fuel for all sources of
transportation the point is i'd like to
have us an immediate solution today is a
bridge technology cng to me is a bridge
technology and then speed up into the
better technology as we go along all
technology must evolve
did you have a question two questions
first
is there a website for your green feed
initiative
you mentioned the 54 penalty for the
importing uh brazilian sugar ethanol and
what role does the sugar lobby in the
u.s play in that kind of having a
penalty
well
there is a website not for the
greenfleet initiative but for my book
internalcombustionbook.com
and there are some articles that i've
written around for various newspapers
around the country on the green fleet
initiative which i invented which i have
no one's permission to do but which i'm
doing all over the united states and i
would encourage anyone who knows a fleet
manager or who has dated the fleet
manager or can find a fleet manager to
shake this guy by the head and ask him
to please buy alternative fuel vehicles
and what was your second question
lobbies are important because the
country wants this to happen now there's
no one in this country who wants
brazilian sugarcane ethanol to uh to
be excluded as an alternative there's no
one in this country who wants uh the oil
companies to get an eight billion dollar
uh government subsidy to have a
motivation to dig for oil there's no one
in this country who wants sugarcane
ethanol
to provide a 51 cent per gallon bonus
this is like
this is like really giving green stamps
to your drug dealer and
the lobbies
are working day and night
it's your problem day and night but
who's really working on it day and night
and i will tell you this
uh trust your instincts before you trust
a lobbyist on this question
may i have a question from you what
about nuclear power uh the the
environmentalists basically put an end
to the building of new uh new nuclear
power plants now it's not the be all and
end all of anything but it is a hell of
a lot cleaner uh europe there are huge
nuclear plants that provide most of the
energy there and they don't
provide they don't the question was a
good one it's nuclear power because i
want people to understand
uh and how much more time do i have
before we have to go for the signing
what
153
153 we got seven minutes okay um
uh
transportation is only 63 percent
of our energy usage there is a question
how do you generate electricity
there's enough wind
in north dakota
to provide 40 percent of of america's
energy needs texas is just behind them
four states alone can generate enough
electricity to each cover 40 of our
electrical needs
uh solar
nano solar bacterial there's lots of
ways to generate
what is a nuclear reactor how does the
nuclear reactor work does anyone in this
room know how a nuclear reactor
generates electricity
it's a water boiler
it's a
multi-billion dollar
decade long effort to make a water
boiler it's the most elaborate expensive
water boiling device since cavemen
and and it's just to turn
a turbine to make electricity and
instead of doing that over 10 years why
not get our wind infrastructure in place
why not get nano solar in place why not
get solar in place and i'm not talking
about these large solar panels i'm
talking about nano solar i'm talking
about roll out solar and i'm talking
about all the many alternatives that we
have beside taking 10 years folks we
don't have 10 years we don't have 10
years i i hope we have 10 months
because the moment when the hurricane
will come either from the golfer from
the middle east will come in a twinkle
of an eye and not at a time of your
choosing
a next question sir here
how to fuel the air the
airplane that's a that's a good question
there is right now
a development by boeing in spain to run
airplanes off of
hydrogen fuel
i don't know enough about it and there's
this has been a many year process
and more that of that needs to be done
because the airplanes are creating a
great deal of pollution and a great deal
of uh um the cost of our transportation
sector uh i'll take a question from you
man you get the green fleet momentum
going when the short-term cost has to be
so great
all right
forget about that short-term cost
because
the real price of a gallon of gas could
be between 15 and 50 dollars a gallon
depending upon the way you look at it
what's going to happen if we go back to
the oil shock
what's going to happen if we go back to
lines
i mean
we had an oil shock in this country the
arabs cut off the oil
and brazil got busy and
now they're 100 energy efficient and
what did gm and ford give us they gave
us the navigator the escalade and the
hummer
and so you must look at when someone
says to you
there's no oil how you get to work
how do you get to to the kidney dialysis
center how do you pick up your child
cost is going to be a very different
issue what i'm trying to do is trying to
get to to get people
to solve the crisis
before the crisis comes to them
uh was there one more question a
question from gal
first of all thank you edwin for a a
fascinating presentation uh i
thought about natural gas
and i think how do you reconcile the
need to
move out of the middle east and from
dictators and so forth when the number
one owner of natural gas in the world is
mr putin and the second largest owner is
mr ahmadinejad
and
between the two of them they own
more than half of the world's reserves
of natural gas
so is that a good idea to shift from
oil owned by corrupt
ruthless dictators to another form of
energy that is owned by just as bad
that's a great question put very well by
an expert
and the answer is
uh not only is clean natural gas not
clean it's also not a great idea but
it's a it's a very very bad
good temporary move it's a it's a
compromise move i've called it a bridge
technology
because you can do it today
and because we do have sources of of
natural gas in the in the united states
there's a ton of it under texas and
everything that's that gal says is
absolutely correct but what's important
to me right now is petropolitical is
getting off the gas station
getting off the oil supply and moving
very very very quickly i'm not talking
about years and decades i'm talking
about months and years to another source
of energy and that will not be
compressed natural gas that'll be
that'll be biodiesel that'll be methanol
that'll be plug in electric uh brazilian
sugar cane that'll be hydrogen hydrogen
is what i'm betting uh our future on
i'll take just one more question from
the back
sugarcane ethanol
polluting
what's the environmental impact impact
of sugar again sugarcane ethanol in its
production
sure we have to be realistic about this
and look on many levels sugarcane
ethanol in its production is
non-polluting because it uses a green
byproduct called magaz in refinement it
doesn't have to dig and truck hundreds
of tons a day of coal and ship them
across the country but the fact is you
must remember
that if a non-polluting car
a perfect zero emission car is
manufactured by a polluting factory you
have another level of pollution to think
about we can only tackle these things in
different ways but the answer is i think
i will agree that sugarcane ethanol out
of the out of the tailpipe is
fundamentally non-polluting thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen if anyone
wants the book i'll be out there
[Applause]
edwin black is the author of six books
including ibm and the holocaust and
banking on baghdad for more information
on his latest work visit internal
combustion book
dot com
[Music]